the manticores tavern has been in the
movie for a long time as a set-piece but
we used to meet someone very different
there we met a hostess named Genevieve
or Jenny for short she was a teenage
satyr who desperately wanted to be a
part of quests and adventure she ended
up partnering up with the boys to go on
the quest in this sequence called
partnership
they're not elf brothers you are safe
from danger dad are you okay oh good
he's alright wait I need to get back in
there and get the map you mean this map
uh-huh you got one you are the world's
greatest waitress thank you so much
sorry to race off but we got a long way
to walk wait take me with you
what why do you want to come with us
because I want to be a real warrior a
warrior I only took this job because I
thought the manticore could teach me
battle techniques but all he ever taught
me was how to refill the ketchups my
whole life I've dreamt of being an
actual warrior and going on a real quest
like yours this isn't a quest of course
it is you're a wizard kind of and yeah
what are you
magic finder okay that sounds made-up
hey but still you guys have a map and
you're on a noble journey to meet your
father that's totally a quest hello sir
nice to meet you my name is Jenny yeah
he can't hear you if you succeed in this
adventure you could inspire a new
generation of magical quests and that is
a world I want to live in let me join
you I will vow to protect you and help
me succeed in meeting your father with
every test of my strength
[Music]